it's a new trend to help afford the
Finer Things in life moving back in with
the parents survival a new report
reveals young adults are heading back to
the nest to avoid the effects of
inflation on rent while splurging on
travel and fashion in exchange it is
really
we still live at home 20
. I'll via Zoom as she was getting ready
to board a plane in California heading
back to Las Vegas she says it's a trip
she was able to pay because she lives
with her parents to me a little bit of
Lululemon Target nothing too crazy
um but in terms I really just try to
save my money as much as I can data from
a Pew Research Center suggests nearly
half of young adults ages 18 to 29 are
living at home with their parents it's a
little bit stressful but uh I'm trying
to basically build this foundation for
myself so that when I do move out I'm
not in a bad position 21 year old Ashley
lybig also feeling the burden but says
living on her own in Las Vegas was not
possible even with two jobs and
finishing school I have a few friends or
acquaintances that were like all right
you're 18 get out of the house the
report States when Millennials and gen Z
young adults free up their budget for
daily Necessities they simply have more
disposable income to allocate to
discretionary spending where luxury
retailers benefits I would never go and
buy
because at the
what am I going to do with this stuff
like that's very high price like two
three thousand
I mean at that point you might as well
just buy an apartment
well both Ashley and Jade tell us they
work full time while going to school and
student housing and lower other lower
rent options which is not an option for
them adding living at home is the best
option for them